for the first time a louisville police  officer has been found criminally  responsible in the killing of briana  taylor former detective kelly goodlett  pleaded guilty to a charge of conspiracy  yesterday in federal court she admitted  conspiring conspiring with another  officer to falsify the search warrant  used in the raid that led to taylor's  death the 26-year-old emt was shot in  march of 2020 after police burst into  the apartment where she was sleeping  goodlett resigned earlier this month  after the justice department announced  new charges against her and three other  officers the others are accused of civil  rights violations conspiracy obstruction  and use of excessive force goodlett will  be sentenced in november and could face  up to five years in prison